A good life was almost seen. I used to be a colonel. So a colonel under said he doesn't
make any of his supplements. He's our private label. Just like ours, our name on it,
our private label too. Really the best life was almost seen now is the one from New
Medica, and we private label that one. So in the New Medica brand, it's because of what
they use as the fact. So we call it clear life was almost seen. I think it's on our
store. It sold in our private label as clear life was almost seen or it sold in the New
Medica label, just like us, and we'll see the New Medica brand. That's those are the best brands.
I use there, I use that the clear curcuclear, which is New Medica's clear, New Medica's
life was almost curcumin. I guess we love that product. I take that probably to tell you
about it really helps, which is totally body inflammation. Also side note there are
private label included clear, which is like it was over a good size over the system. Great
product to help just the detox pathways to take that one as well. With low dose, no
trexone, low dose, no trexone, 0.5 milligrams, starting out daily is the protocol to increase
or some time. Yes, so again, you'll have to talk to the prescribing doctor since this is
a medication, but I can't tell you what is the typical dosage. Typical low dose, no trexone,
you start at 1.5. So I don't know why this doctor has you started at 0.5. Typical low
dose, no trexone, you start at 1.5 for a couple weeks, then you move up to 3.0 for a couple
weeks, and then you move to 4.5. Put it in a person's weight. So if they're a TD person,
they might just stay at 3.0. But if they're a male of 170 to 250 pounds, you'll go up to 4.5
milligrams there. So I don't allow you starting with something low dose, let's ask for prescribing
doctor. With mistletoe IV or objection, is this worth trying? Yeah, I think it's worth trying.
The only thing I'd caution anybody about is don't try too many things at the same time.
You don't know what's really helping you. Mistletoe IV and mistletoe injections,
a whole idea of mistletoe, it's an irritant that stimulates the immune response. So there are side
effects to that. So you'll get a fever, you can feel icky, there's a bunch of different side effects
that go along with mistletoe, and quite honestly, that actually means it's working. So if you're doing
mistletoe injections in your belly, you do it above your belly button, and you're not getting this
huge red reaction, this irritation, then you're not using the correct dosage. So you do, just just
remember that.